je suis l'officier de protection qui va
instruire votre demande d'asile rien de
ce que vous direz sur vos craintes dans
votre pays d'origine ne sortira de cette
pièce voilà c'est la première phrase que
les officiers de protection de l'office
français de protection des réfugiés et
apatrides que je dirige prononce
lorsqu'ils reçoivent à fontenay sous
bois en région parisienne plus de 200
hommes et femmes
chaque jour pour un entretien afin que
nous puissions statuer sur leurs
demandes d'asile
ils ont été en 2015 80000 accueilli à
l'ofpra
mais pour d'où ces demandeurs d'asile ne
sont pas des chiffres ce sont des
visages ce sont des histoires ce sont
des récits de souffrance des visages et
des histoires jetés sur les routes de
l'exil depuis l'afghanistan depuis la
syrie depuis l'irak depuis le soudan
depuis l'erythrée d'autres pays encore
ils fuient les guerres et des
persécutions
c'est terrible parcours qui font que
nous sommes plongés chaque jour dans ces
terribles convulsions du monde c'est
d'un privilège redoutable et noble que
nous partageons d'ailleurs avec les
associations avec les travailleurs
sociaux dans les centres d'hébergement
avec des élus avec les citoyens de ce
pays qui accompagnent des demandeurs
d'asile
tout au long de ce parcours mais l'ofpra
a une mission
quelque part
avec nul autre qui est son exclusivité
qui est le statuer sur les demandes
d'asile
lorsqu'à l'issue de ce parcours qui les
conduit le plus souvent d'allemagne mais
aussi parfois en france ces personnes
sollicitent la protection de la france
au nom du droit d'asile
nous avons une obsession nous avons un
mot d'ordre il est de tout faire pour ne
jamais passer à côté d'un besoin de
protection je revois cette la
satisfaction de ses officiers de
protection alors que nous avions décidé
de protéger une jeune nigériane placés
en rétention
parce que victimes d'un réseau de
proxénètes et voulant s'en dissocier
nous allions pouvoir la protéger mais
lorsqu'une demande d'asile à l'issue
d'une instruction à laquelle chaque
demandeur d'asile a droit ne relèvent
pas du droit d'asile notre
responsabilité est de rejeter cette
demande il ya quelques semaines encore
dans un ascenseur de l'ofpra croisant
l'une de nos collègues que je voyais
marquer et je m'en inquiétais auprès
d'elle elle sortait d'un entretien avec
un jeune homme venu d'un pays d'afrique
elle avait cherché afin de pouvoir le
protéger et rien dans son dossier me dit
elle ne le permet et elle a eu cette
phrase ce garçon à mon âge j'ai cherché
je ne pourrais pas le protéger je vais
donc vous proposer de rejeter sa demande
d'asile
car ces demandes
ces décisions de l'ofpra ce sont des
décisions humaines
ce sont des hommes des femmes qui les
prennent mais ce sont des décisions en
droit nous appliquons tant que nous
pouvons la convention de genève afin de
reconnaître à ces hommes et ces femmes à
ses petites filles à ses enfants
le statut de réfugié lorsque leur
engagement politique
leurs croyances religieuses leur
appartenance ethnique leur orientation
sexuelle parfois conduite à ne plus
pouvoir imaginer le retour dans leur
pays où ils ont subi ces persécutions
il ya dans notre pays
un jeune irakien ahmed armes est gelée
rencontrer les équipes de l'offre à
munich en septembre 2015 au moment où
des centaines de milliers de personnes
arrivées en allemagne où la société
allemande faisait ce geste admirable de
les accueillir
si nombreux nous étions à la demande des
gouvernements français et allemand
présent à munich pour accueillir
certains de ces réfugiés en france dans
un vaste hall des expositions où les
gens passaient et repartait et il y
avait là ahmad
il venait il tournait autour de nous
hésitant il est venu vers moi un moment
où où j'étais seul pour me demander si
la france protéger les homosexuels
ahmad est un parmi nous en france
aujourd'hui réfugié et lorsque la
convention de genève ne s'applique pas
alors nous cherchons à appliquer la
protection subsidiaire concept et ceux
qui fuient les guerres les conflits
généralisés comme la syrie aujourd'hui
ou comme l'essentiel du territoire
afghan
ou parce que ce sont des traitements
inhumains ou dégradants qui attendrait
ces personnes dans leur pays
et alors nous pouvons les protéger en
application de la protection subsidiaire
ces décisions là ce sont des décisions
en droit et ce sont des décisions
indépendante
l'ofpra le directeur général de l'ofpra
que je suis au nom duquel ces décisions
sont prises n'a le droit de recevoir
d'instructions de quiconque essaie
désormais dans la loi française
ces décisions de l'ofpra
lorsque le statut long sur les demandes
d'asile elles sont prises exclusivement
en fonction de considérations d'asile et
en aucun cas selon des considérations
diplomatiques en aucun cas non plus
selon des considérations de politique
migratoire
je sens et je comprends monter la
tentation
face à l'ampleur des drames la tentation
d'aller au delà du droit d'asile
mais ces tentations sur est pernicieuse
et délétère elle installerait une
confusion dans le droit d'asile in fine
et j'en suis convaincu serait la victime
car ce droit d'asile il évolue et nous
le faisons évoluer dans le sens de la
bienveillance mais aussi de la rigueur
parce que lorsque le droit d'asile
s'impose il doit s'imposer
indépendamment de toute autre forme de
considération
alors ces décisions que nous prenons que
des officiers de protection de l'ofpra
ces hommes ces femmes chaque jour me
propose
elles sont prises à l'issue d'une
instruction que nous voulons chaque fois
plus bienveillante et plus rigoureuse
elles partent de la possibilité
d'essayer achats comme à chaque femme
d'exprimer des raisons pour lesquelles
il ne pourra pas ne pourra pas rentrer
dans son pays
d'abord dans un récit écrit qui nous est
adressé après que la personne soit passé
en préfecture
dans le dossier de demande d'asile et
puis lors de cet entretien où l'officier
protection devra être à l'écouté et ils
sont allés coûte de bannières notamment
à lorsque ces craintes sont si
difficiles a verbalisé parce que nous
sommes dans l'indicible que nous
puissions accompagné l'expression de ses
récits pour des femmes victimes de viols
pour des femmes victimes de violence
conjugale pour des hommes et des femmes
victimes de la torture et qui en
subissent encore les séquelles pour des
mineurs qui sont seuls sur les routes de
l'exil
et puis c'est sur la base de cette
expression l'un de ces craintes en cas
de retour dans le pays d'origine que
l'officier de protection va commencer
une minutieuse instruction qui va le
conduire échanger avec ses collègues
avec des référents spécialisés avec les
juristes de l'ofpra avec les chercheurs
de l'ofpra qui établissent une analyse
indépendante de la situation dans les
pays d'origine et c est à la confluence
de cette instruction et de ces éléments
que sera prise la décision de l'ofpra
une décision que vous nous voulons
encore une fois chaque fois dans la
bienveillance et dans la rigueur
pendant ce temps nous le savons c'est la
tante à la dureté de l'exil s'ajoutent
l'âpreté de la tante administrative car
il nous revient de concilier
l'inconciliable
ce temps là ce temps de l'instruction de
la demande d'asile
il est vital pour ces hommes ces femmes
et ces familles et nous devons concilier
cela avec le temps administratif alors à
cela je ne connais qu'une réponse
l'accueil l'humanité et la rigueur les
délais d'instruction sont encore trop
long nous les réduisons depuis plusieurs
mois et nous allons continuer à les
réduire car nous le devons à ces hommes
et ces femmes et à ces familles nous
avons pour cela pu augmenter les
effectifs de l'opra l'ofpra nous sommes
620 aujourd'hui nos effectifs ont
augmenté de 50%
nous sommes réorganisés en profondeur
cards off prat change
l'ofpra protège plus nous protégeons 20
6 % des demandeurs d'asile là où il ya
trois ans ils étaient 9 % être protégés
35% avec le juge
l'offre est en mouvement va vers les
demandeurs d'asile à calais depuis deux
ans à grande synthe dans les régions
françaises au liban en jordanie en
turquie pour protéger réinstaller en
france
partout la frustration restent trop
souvent présente pour nous face à ceux
qui n'arriveront jamais face à celles et
ceux qui attendent trop longtemps dans
notre pays encore un accueil et une
décision face à celles et ceux dont nous
devons rejeter la demande mais ce qui
nous porte et ce qui va continuer à nous
porter
c'est la mission de protection car c'est
notre mission et c'est le titre que nous
portons nous sommes les officiers de
protection
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]